The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Question.
We know how to do
matching and running.
We've seen an example of that.
In this area, there's this
label v on the fields,
and we want to figure
out how that affects
doing matching and running.
So we started out talking
about the wave function
for normalization calculation.
So we have these
fields, which we
can have a bare version of
and a renormalized version
of in the usual way.
So this is renormalized,
and this is bare.
Some Z factor between them
that I'll call Zh for Z heavy.
And so we have to calculate at
the lowest order, this diagram,
send in a momentum
P. This is Q plus p.?
Use the Feynman rules.
Use dimensional regularization.
Use dimensional
regularization with MS bar,
so there's some extra factors.
And use Feynman gauge, which
is usually the simplest gauge
choice.
So each of these
vertices here gets
a v. There's a v mu
from this vertex.
A v mu from that vertex.
And that's where this
v squared comes from.
And then there's
one propagator here.
It's very traditional
to denote a heavy quark
by two lines rather
than one line,
so you know which
lines are heavy
and which lines are light.
So these two lines
is a heavy quark,
and that gives this propagator
here, this v dot q plus P.
And then there's a relativistic
propagator for the gluon,
and that's the q squared.
I've taken into account all the
i's when I put this minus sign,
and this is just the
fundamental Casimir
from dotting two TAs together.
OK.
So when you have an
integral like this--
so v squared is 1.
That's one simplification.
When you have an
integral like that
where you have a linear
momentum in one propagator
and a quadratic momentum
in the other propagator,
you don't want to use the
standard Feynman trick.
I call this trick
the George I trick.
So it's very similar
to the Feynman trick
but slightly different.
So you use an integral that
goes from 0 to infinity,
and you can convince
yourself that this is true.
And so then set a equal the q
squared and b equal to v dot
q plus p.
And the reason that you'd
want to use this trick rather
than the usual one is that
if you use the usual one,
you'd get an x
multiplying this and a 1
minus x multiplying that.
But then you would have an
x multiplying the q squared.
So when you complete
this, it would
be-- when you'd want
to complete the square,
you'd like nothing to
multiply the q squared.
You'd like the q squared
just to be bare by itself
with no Feynman
parameter multiplying it.
And this trick does
that, because a
has no Feynman parameter
multiplying it,
or George I parameter
in this case.
OK, so we combine
denominators in the usual way,
and the denominator
would become this.
And if I kept the
i epsilon it would
be that if we combine these
two denominators here.
So this factor would be that.
And we can then complete
the square, right.
This is some momentum
squared minus
whatever is left over
where t is q plus lambda v,
and then A is the rest of
the stuff, which is this.
OK, so then this
guy, now we just
have our usual
quadratic integral
that we can use the
standard rules to do.
And then instead of
an integral over x,
we have this
integral over lambda.
There's some factors
that I'm dropping.
So there's that e to the Euler
gamma times epsilon and the 4
pi minus epsilon.
So write in everything with
d equals 4 minus 3 epsilon.
Do that integral, which is just
giving some gamma functions.
And if you think
about the dimensions
here, so we end up with
something that's d minus 3.
If you think-- if you want
to look at the dimensions,
d over 2 minus 2 is
dimensionless, OK.
The lambda had dimensions.
If we go back here,
that's obvious.
q is dimensionful,
v is dimensionless,
so lambda has dimension 1.
So the dimensions of the--
actually, the dimensions
of the mu to the 2 epsilon
are compensating
the dimensions here,
and then there's one
power of dimension left.
And that's why if
I take d equals 4,
I'm getting one power of
momentum upstairs, which
is what we would expect
for an inverse propagator
for a heavy quark, is
1 factor of v dot P.
So expand this.
And we get a divergence.
So add a counter term for
wave function renormalization.
So if we did that in MS bar,
then the Zh would be just this.
And that would be the
appropriate counter term
to kill off the 1 over
epsilon divergence.
I'm going to carry
out the calculation
today, or this discussion
of matching in MS bar
for everything.
And I'll show you some of
the slight complication that
shows up in that case.
But we said that we
could do matching--
basically, you could
have two choices here.
You could either use
on-shell renormalization,
or you could use MS bar.
What's the difference?
In MS bar, you just keep
the divergence in the z.
In on-shell renormalization,
you keep some extra terms here,
all right.
And either way that we
choose to do things,
we should actually end up
with the same matching,
and I want to show
you why that's true.
So in order to show
you why that's true,
I'll pick to use MS
bar at this point,
and we'll see what complication
that leads to later on.
OK, so that's one thing that
needs to be renormalized.
And if we look at this guy
and we compare it to z psi,
this is not the same
as z psi in QCD.
So this is something
different, and the reason
it's different is because
we did a different loop
integral that had this
heavy quark propagator, not
the light quark propagator.
So we have to renormalize
also local operators.
And so let's think about
something that would make
a heavy to light transition.
So for example, if you
looked at b goes to u,
electron neutrino,
then that would
be a heavy to light transition.
To b quark is heavy.
The b quark is light.
So to describe
that, you would use
some operator that has one
heavy quark and one light quark.
So let me call the light quark
small q and the heavy quark
big Q. And so you'd have some
operator looks like that.
And we could write down
a renormalized operator
with renormalized fields and
then group all the z factors
into a counter term.
So let's think about doing the
perturbation theory that way.
So this is the
renormalized operator.
This is the counter term.
So there's a wave function
factor Zq for the light quark
and Zh for the heavy
quark, and then there's
some Zo for the operator
renormalization.
OK, so to renormalize
this operator at one loop,
we insert it, and we
do a one-loop diagram.
I'm just going to
tell you the answers,
but let's draw the diagram.
So here's the operator inserted.
Here's your heavy quark.
Here's your light quark.
You have a diagram like that.
And then you combine this
calculation with the wave
function renormalize Zh and Zq.
Zq is the same as Z psi.
We should've called this
Zq for the light quark.
Combine these things
together, and then,
because that graph is telling
you to count this counter term,
you need Zo.
And that calculation, which
you can look at in your reading
if you want to look
at more details,
just gives you something
about what you'd expect.
It gives you a 1 over epsilon
divergence factor of g squared.
So the operator here has
renormalization that's
just minus alpha s over pi.
That's the anomalous dimension.
So what is this anomalous
dimension doing?
If you were to consider this
kind of process in full QCD,
then you'd have here
gamma mu 1 minus 5,
and that's a partially
conserved current.
So there would be actually
no anomalous dimension
to this operator.
The vertex graph that
we just drew over
there would cancel the wave
function graphs exactly.
There'd be no
anomalous dimension.
But here we have one.
And that's because these guys
are not equivalent anymore.
You saw that the Z for
the heavy quark changed,
and the vertex
graph also changes.
And we're left with something.
And this remainder has to do
with renormalization group
evolution below the
mass of the heavy quark.
Above the mass of
the heavy quark,
there's no renormalize group
evolution of this current.
Below the mass of the
heavy quark, there is.
So there's additional
logs, and that's
because MQ is now being
treated as infinite.
So things that, from the point
of view of QCD, were logs of MQ
have now become UV
divergences, and that gives
an extra anomalous dimension.
One thing you can note about
this anomalous dimension
is that I didn't really specify
for you what the gamma was.
I told you for this process it
would be gamma mu 1 minus gamma
5.
And the results here,
actually, if you carry out
this calculation
with arbitrary gamma,
you find that it's
independent of gamma.
So you get the same universal
anomalous convention
for any spin structure.
And that's partly
related to the things
that we talked about last time
with the spin symmetry of HQET,
which is telling you that
certain couplings are not
sensitive to the spin.
And effectively,
in this diagram,
you're getting a v slash here.
Well, let me not
try to go through it
but leave it for looking
at in your reading,
but we'll talk a little bit
more about this in a minute.
I won't try to
explain where that
comes from from the diagram.
So let's look at another case.
The only real interesting
thing that happened here
was that we got-- well, the
fact that the answer was
non-0 was interesting,
and the fact that it
was independent of gamma.
But the v didn't show up.
And the reason that the v didn't
show up in this calculation
here is because
there was only one v,
and v squared was equal to 1.
So v couldn't really
show up because we
had to get a scalar answer, and
since v squared is equal to 1,
just, it's not showing up.
So something more interesting
is to look at, instead
of a heavy to light
transition like that,
a heavy to heavy transition.
So we'll spend a little
bit more time on this one.
So let's have two heavy fields.
And I'm going to take
them in a current
where they have different
velocities, v and v prime.
So let me imagine I went through
this procedure of separating
out counter term and
renormalized the operator just
like I did over there.
So I have these two terms,
two types of structures.
Now I don't have a Zq, but
I have two heavy quarks.
So I have Zh, root Zh
root Zh, which is just Zh.
So an example of this
would be something
like B meson changing to,
say, a D star meson electron
and a neutrino, so having a
charm quark replace our up
quark.
OK, so now the charm
quark and the B quark
could both be
thought of as heavy.
They have different masses, but
we take both of those masses
to infinity, so we can
use HQET for both of them.
So Mb and Mc are
going to infinity.
And there's no reason
why, in this process,
that the b quark
and the charm quarks
should have the same
velocity, and so we'll
give them different
velocities, v and v prime.
OK, so we can go
through the same thing.
We already calculated
Zh, so we just
have to calculate a
graph like this or two,
where you have two heavy quarks.
But the heavy quarks have
different velocities.
So what would that
calculation look like?
Again in Feynman gauge,
and let me just take
the external quarks to have
zero momentum for simplicity,
zero residual momentum.
So this guy has k
equals 0 and k equals 0.
So the HQET Feynman
rule for this guy
has a v dot q if q
is the loop momenta,
and this guy has a
v prime dot q, OK.
So the integral that have
to do is that integral.
And you can do this again
with one of these tricks where
you use lambda parameters.
And then one of the
handouts on the web page,
I've given you the
appropriate trick
that's two lambda parameters
for this integral.
This integral actually
has both ultraviolet
and infrared divergences.
We're here in our
discussion only
interested in the
ultraviolet ones,
because we're worrying about the
anomalous dimension right now.
And again, I'm not
going to drag you
through the details
of this calculation.
It's essentially just,
do the Feynman parameter,
combine denominators with
two Feynman parameters,
complete the square,
do the loop integral,
do the Feynman parameter
integrals, get an answer.
Combine it together with the
counter terms of the wave
function renormalize, and
see what type of counter term
you get left over.
And it's more interesting
than the heavy to light case.
So here's what it looks like,
where w is v dot v prime,
and this function, r
of w, is the following.
It's log w plus square
root w squared minus 1
over the square root
of w squared minus 1.
OK, so it's a
non-trivial structure.
So that counter term would
lead to an anomalous dimension,
which depends on this r of w.
So the reason that
that can happen
is because v squared is
1, v prime squared is 1,
but v dot v prime need not be 1.
So v squared was 1, v
prime squared was 1,
but v dot v prime is not fixed.
Well, it's not fixed simply by--
that's a poor choice of words.
This is a parameter
that can vary.
So it will be fixed
by kinematics,
but it can depend
on the kinematics.
So let me go through
this and organize it
as a bunch of notes, comments.
So this is what I just said.
The answer depends
on v dot v prime.
And the way that you
should think about this
is that you have a current
in the effective theory.
So this is in the HQET current.
And just like we label it
by its Lorentz index mu,
we should label it also
by the v and v prime,
because the fields
involve v and v prime.
So if we thought of this as some
vector current or axial vector
current labeled by mu, we
would also label the current
by v and v prime.
So these are indices that are
just indices on the current,
and when you think
about the Wilson
coefficient or the
anomalous dimension,
it can depend on those indices.
Now because the Wilson
coefficient is a scalar,
it really only depends on w.
So if you think about
Wilson coefficients,
they depend on alpha s.
They depend on scale mu.
They depend on the hard
scales in your problem,
and the hard scales
in the problem
here for us are Mb times
v and Mc times v prime,
because those are the heavy
scales of the heavy charm
quark and the heavy b
quark that we're removing.
But since we know that
this thing is a scalar,
we can just square these,
dot them into each other.
So it's really a function of
mu of alpha s mu Mb squared,
from squaring the Mb term,
M charm squared, and then
this w factor.
Those are the scalar
quantities it can depend on.
So what should I take for the w?
Well, we could work
that out for an example
like the one I was saying that
we're doing, B to D star L nu.
So I want to show
you how that works.
So for the B meson,
for momentum,
we can take it to be M
capital B meson times v mu.
And by momentum
conservation, that's
going to be the D
star momentum, which
we can take to be MD
Star times v prime mu
then some momentum
transfer, which I call q.
This is a different q
than my loop momentum q.
Sorry about that.
So then we can just take this
relation, and we can square it,
and we can get v dot v primes.
So if you look at 2 squared,
we can solve this for v dot v
prime, and it's just fixed.
You see that v dot v prime is
fixed in terms of the meson
masses and the
momentum transfer,
and that's the momentum
transfer to the leptons here.
How much momentum
do they carry away?
So you could think of all
those things as external.
You fixed how much momentum
the leptons carry away.
These are fixed numbers.
You look them up in the PDG,
and then what value of v
dot v prime to plug-in here.
Now it's a function
of q squared.
Q squared can vary
in the process.
So in that sense, it's a
non-trivial function, not just
a fixed number.
But for any fixed
kinematic configuration,
any fixed q, then it
would just be a number.
So if you look at
this in practice,
you find that this guy
for this particular case
goes from 1 to 1.5.
So that's the kinematic
range that's allowed.
So it is fixed by external
kinematics, kinematics
that is external to the
dynamics inside the loop.
And then that way,
the Wilson coefficient
here is more non-trivial
than the ones we saw earlier,
which just depended on masses.
Now it's depending on masses
as well as this function
of v dot v prime, OK?
Again, one finds that
gamma T comes out
to be exactly the same,
independent of the choice
of the spin structure.
So we could do this calculation
with any spin structure
we like, and heavy quark
symmetry in this case
is all it takes to show that
this gamma T is independent
of the spin structure.
So if you think about
that from the loop graph,
actually in this case,
it's pretty easy to see,
because remember that this
vertex didn't have any spin
structure.
The propagator had
no spin structure.
So nothing in the calculation
had spin structure.
So the only thing that's
had spin structure
is the gamma you stuck in there.
So it's just a
scalar times gamma,
so it doesn't care
about the gamma.
On whatever the tree level
gamma is, it just goes through.
It's not touched by heavy
quark, by the HQET Lagrangian.
So what is physically
going on here,
and what is HQET
doing for you is
that there's logs like this,
MQ over lambda QCD and QCD.
And by going over to
HQET, this becomes a log
of mu over lambda
QCD, which is encoded
in HQET operators
like this current,
as well as a log
of mu over MQ or MQ
over mu, which is in the HQET
coefficient functions, HQET
Wilson coefficients.
So just how we--
much exactly the same
as how we talked about
it for integrating out
a heavy particle, the logs
get split up into pieces,
and the Wilson coefficient
into pieces, and the matrix
elements, operators.
Here we're separating
MQ heavy quark mass,
and it's both the charm and
the bottom in the case of what
we're talking about.
And the anomalous dimension
that we calculated sums up those
logs, and summing up those logs
involves a non-trivial function
of this w.
But we actually know exactly
the non-trivial function,
because we can calculate it.
And it's just this guy here.
OK, so the new wrinkle
that can come in HQET
is that the anomalous
dimension can become a more
non-trivial thing.
So if you look at it
at leading log order,
the rest is pretty
straightforward.
So if you go through
the leading log result,
you would do the same type
of thing that we did before.
You would match it, some scale.
And at that scale, you
could normalize things
so that the Wilson coefficient
at mu equals MQ is just 1
at tree level.
And then the leading log
result is the function
of these various things,
which in general is C of MQ
times some evolution
from MQ to mu,
suppressing some of
the dependencies.
The leading log
result is 1 for this.
And then this guy
at the lowest order
is just a ratio of alphas again.
And then there's the gamma.
For the purpose of
solving the RGE is just,
the only thing that
matters is it's alpha.
So a gamma's a constant for
heavy to light, just a number.
So for that current,
it was a constant.
This solution is actually
valid for both of them.
And then it's a function of
this w for the current, where
we have two heavy quarks.
So the w dependence
just goes along
for the ride when you're
solving the anomalous dimension
equation.
OK?
So that's what re-summing
the logs would look like.
Essentially, each log
is getting extra powers
of this factor of gamma.
So with number four, is there
any questions about that?
OK, pretty straightforward.
So much of this, essentially
all of the story,
except for this one wrinkle, is
very similar to integrating out
a massive particle.
And the other part of
the story that's similar
is that the HQET matrix
elements depend on mu as well.
And so in our example that
we talked about last time,
we had a matrix element.
So let me give it to you in
the context of that example.
So last time we were
talking about something
which was a decay constant,
and that's one example
of this heavy to light current.
So we had our current which
had one heavy quark, one
light quark, and
then a heavy meson.
And we figured out that this
was giving some a times v mu,
and now I'm telling you that
you should think of the a
as a function of mu.
The matrix element here
is a function of mu.
OK, so that's just a
slight modification to what
we talked about last time.
And again, if you want,
for this matrix element,
you'd want mu to be, say,
a GeV or some scale that's
greater than lambda QCD,
and so what you would do
is you would evaluate
matrix elements
and define that parameter
at some scale like a GeV
and do renormalization group
evolution from the heavy quark
mass down to a GeV.
OK?
So that's how the
renormalization group evolution
story would be.
You don't want to run all
the way down to lambda QCD,
because the anomalous dimension
has to remain perturbative.
So you would decide
what your cutoff
is for where you think
perturbation theory is still
valid.
Often people pick something like
1 GeV or 1 1/2 GeV for these
types of problems.
And again, this is just
separating out all the MQs,
making sure that your matrix
element here has no MQs,
it does have an extra cutoff mu.
OK?
So that's the RGE story.
Let's also talk a little bit
about the matching story.
So these are the perturbative
corrections at the scale MQ,
or alpha s at MQ.
We had perturbative
corrections at the w scale
when we integrated
out the w boson.
Now we have another set of
perturbative corrections
at the heavy quark mass
scale when we integrated
out the heavy quark mass.
It's different because we're
now passing from something
that looked like
a full QCD theory
with some external operators.
We're now passing to this HQET
theory for the heavy quark.
So if you like, we
previously had Mw.
We knew how to do
renormalization group
evolution there, and we
had a Hw theory here.
Now we integrate out
the heavy quark mass,
and we pass to an HQET
theory below that scale.
So if you go back to the Hw
theory, if we can call it that,
and we want to match
that onto HQET,
then we do it with a
calculation like this.
And I'll just use this
heavy, light example still.
So here's a matrix
element that you could
consider for the matching.
And let me write it with a
bunch of schematic objects
and then explain what they are.
So we use our spinners.
I'm taking zero momentum
here, just for simplicity.
These Rs are residue
factors that come in.
So so far when we calculated the
wave function renormalization
graphs, we just took
the divergent piece.
And if you do that when you
do the matching computation,
you have to use LSZ.
And so the finite
pieces come back in,
and you call them residues.
So these are finite residues
that you have to take account
of, finite in the UV sense.
So UV finite residues you have
to take into account if you're
just using MS bar,
and this here would
be the vertex
renormalization graph.
OK, both diagrams
look like this.
In QCD, they're both the
same type of structure.
And then in HQET,
it's a similar thing.
We can write down a
formula for the s matrix
element, the same states,
now with our effective theory
current.
And we know how to transition
from effective theory
and full theory states.
We talked about that last time.
And so there again would
be some residue factors.
And if the residue
factors are not
the same in the two theories,
you have to account for that.
And they won't be, because
one of the heavy quark residue
will be different than the
heavy quark residue here.
So this guy here is this
finite piece of this graph.
This guy here will
be the same as above.
And this guy here is
the heavy quark vertex
graph, which is independent
of the spin structure.
It's not independent of the
spin structure up there.
So we could carry out the
calculations of those loop
diagrams, and then
we could subtract,
and we could see
what's left over.
And whatever's left over
is the Wilson coefficient.
OK, so very similar
to what we did before.
Calculate, subtract.
What you find when you do
that is that there's actually
two currents.
If you consider a vector
current where gamma is gamma mu,
then the effective field
theory, which is HQET,
has two effective theory
currents that are vector.
So you have C1 and C2.
The reason that there's two is
because we have another vector
to play with, which is v mu.
So that can have q bar v
mu replacing the gamma mu.
So v mu wasn't an
external thing in QCD.
It was part of the dynamics.
Here it's an external
thing, so it's
allowed to replace gamma mu
as one of the structures.
And if you go through
the calculation,
this is the result, just to show
you what the result looks like.
Remember, the
heavy to light case
is the case where you're not
getting a non-trivial function
on the right hand side.
So you'd get a non-zero
result of order alpha
s for both of those
coefficients, OK?
So the reading also goes
through this whole thing
for the heavy to heavy case,
which is more interesting.
But it's not really more
non-trivial than what
we've talked about
so far already
with anomalous dimension.
You get results that
are functions of w.
Wilson coefficient would have
functions of w showing up here,
OK.
So I won't go through that.
Now if you wanted to carry
out this calculation,
it looks like it's
kind of involved,
this graph, this
graph, this graph,
all these diagrams to consider.
You'd like to make your
life as easy as possible,
and there's actually
a very nice trick here
for doing that I have
to mention to you,
because it's kind of magical.
So what is the fastest way
that I could get this result?
So this is a nice trick
to remember if you ever
have to do a
calculation like that,
because it's not
specific to HQET.
So let's pick our
infrared regulator
to make the effective theory
as simple as possible.
We have some choice in how to
pick the infrared regulator.
The result for
Wilson coefficients
and anomalous dimensions will
not depend on that choice.
So let's use that
freedom and make
things as simple as we can.
And the choice
that does that here
is to use dimensional
regularization for the UV,
as we've been discussing,
but also for the infrared.
So let's use dimensional
regularization for both.
If you do that, you can convince
yourself that all heavy quark
effective theory graphs with
on-shell external momentum--
so I can take the external
momentum on-shell.
I don't need it to
regulate divergences,
because I'm going to
use div reg to do that.
So all the integrals
are scaleless,
and that means that they come
out to be something that,
if you think about it, is either
zero or zero in a way where you
have the ultraviolet divergence
cancelling an infrared
divergence, which is still zero.
Now you have to
think about the fact
that there's both
of these going on,
because you still have
to think about adding
counter terms to HQET to
cancel the UV divergences.
But the answers are very simple,
because you can throw away
all the finite pieces.
If you have 1 over
epsilon minus 1
over epsilon, if you multiply by
epsilon, that term's not there.
So 1 over epsilon gets
removed by counter terms,
and there's no finite
pieces left over.
So just use MS bar, so you
just strip off that exactly,
and you're left with
1 over epsilon IR.
Now if you-- so the effective
theory diagrams are just
simply all 1 over epsilon IR.
Now the reason that this
is making things simple
is because you also
know a fact, which
is that the IR divergences
in the full theory
and the effective
theory have to match up.
So these 1 over epsilon
IRs have to match up
with your full
theory calculation.
So if you renormalize the
QCD calculation, which
you can't really
get around doing,
you have to do that calculation.
So you do that calculation
in pure dim reg, same IR
regulator, which is a nice
regulator to use for QCD.
You do the UV renormalization
using the standard counter
terms, and what will you get?
You will get
something that looks
like a number over epsilon
IR, and then you'll
get numbers times logs mu
over MQ plus other things.
This thing here just cancels
with the-- if I subtract HQET,
this is just canceling this.
So this guy here cancels
when we subtract HQET.
And so the matching
is then just this.
So I don't actually even have to
consider calculating the heavy.
If I use all these facts
that I know, if I trust them,
then I don't even have to
calculate the HQET graphs.
I just say, let me imagine
that I calculate them.
They're all scaleless.
They look like that.
Let me imagine that I
renormalized them all.
The 1 over epsilon UVs are gone.
I'm left with 1
over epsilon IRs.
I do this calculation.
I say, let me imagine that
these cancel each other.
And then I have the matching.
So that's exploiting
all the facts
that we know about effective
theories and full theories
to get the matching as
quickly as possible by just
doing the full
theory calculation
with a particular regulator.
It's not checking anything.
It's not checking that the full
theory and the effective theory
have the IR divergences matching
up, et cetera, et cetera.
But if you know
that that's true,
if you trust that
it's true, then this
is the fastest way
to get the matching.
Seems like magic, right?
OK, so sometimes
you can exploit what
you know about the
effective theory
to get things more quickly.
So questions about that?
AUDIENCE: What is [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if you think about
the loop integral,
then the d here,
right, and 4 minus 2
epsilon have an
epsilon greater than 0,
decreasing the powers of q in
the numerator is making it more
UV convergent.
So to regulate the
IR, you want to have
epsilon on the other side.
So this is what you
need for regulating IR,
and this is what you
need for regulating UV.
So it may seem contradictory
that you could even
do both of these things
at the same time,
because greater than
zero and less than zero.
But you could always think
of splitting up this integral
with a hard cutoff somewhere
in between and then
just using this above and
this below that cutoff.
And the cutoff dependence
will cancel when you
put the pieces back together.
So it's actually valid
to just do calculations.
And for the most part, you
can just close your eyes,
and you'll get some
gamma of epsilons
and some gamma of
minus epsilons,
and those will be separately
regulating the divergences.
And if you ever worry about
it, you can do what I said.
You could put a cutoff in
and check that you're not
making mistakes, but
for the most part,
it just works automatically.
Any other--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] all of the
epsilon UV [INAUDIBLE] epsilon
IR.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] minus
epsilon UV [INAUDIBLE] zero
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --negative.
AUDIENCE: But formally,
you can set the epsilon
UV plus an epsilon IR.
PROFESSOR: That's right, yeah.
So formally, this is zero.
And the reason that you
have to worry about zero
is because you have to add a
counter term to cancel this.
Your UV counter term,
you have to still add it.
And then it cancels
this, and then you
get something non-zero.
So the bare graph is zero.
The counter term's
non-zero, and there
renormalized graph is non-zero.
This is a subtlety that's worth
remembering if you ever want
to do calculations this way.
OK, so that's some
of the complications
and fascinating facts about
HQET in the perturbative sector.
Let's come back and talk about
power corrections, which are--
I'll go under the
title of-- well,
maybe I should just call
them power corrections.
Better title.
So we have an effective theory.
We've so far talked
about it at lowest order.
We stopped at lowest order.
We had this HQET
Lagrangian, and we
talked about using that
Lagrangian to carry out
some perturbative calculations.
What if we went to higher
order in the power [INAUDIBLE]
expansion, which is 1 over MQ?
OK, so power corrections
here means higher order
in 1 over MQ.
So let me show you how you
can construct those terms.
So let me go back to a
representation of the full QCD
Lagrangian, which we had in
terms of this B field and the Q
field.
And when we first
talked about this,
we just dropped all
the terms of the B,
but now I'm going to do
something a little more
sophisticated with them and
really just integrate them out.
So we had this,
and this was really
just us writing QCD in
a fancy way that was
convenient for this discussion.
So this is really just QCD
written in a fancy way.
So if we want to take this
Lagrangian at tree level,
we can just integrate out Bv.
This is a Lagrangian that has
quadratic dependence on Bv.
So you could think that the
path interval in this formula
here would be quadratic
path interval, and those
we can always just solve.
And what effectively
integrating out Bv amounts
to is solving for the
equations of motion of Bv
and plugging that back in.
So the type of
diagrams I was drawing
before where I had
this wiggly line
and it was a Bv propagator,
we can integrate out that
by solving for the
equation of motion.
So we look for
variation with respect
to Bv bar and set it to 0.
And that gives this
equation, and then
we solve this formally for Bv
by just inverting this operator
to get that equation.
And then we can plug
that equation back
into this equation,
which is still a QCD
Lagrangian, actually, but--
and then we expand.
And once we expand, we match
onto the HQET Lagrangian order
by order, tree level.
So the first term is the
term we've been discussing.
The next term, we drop the v dot
D here, because that's small.
We just have 1 over 2 Q.
There's two D transverses,
and they'd be higher
order terms as well,
but we'll stop in that order.
So this is L0, first order
term, and this would be L1.
They'd be higher order terms.
So what is this guy?
It's useful to write
that guy, actually,
in terms of two
different things,
and you'll see why momentarily.
So it's got two covariant
derivatives, and both of them
are dotted into gamma matrices.
It involves this thing, D
transverse, which, remember,
is the full D minus
a projection onto
v. So it's something
that's transverse to v. So
what I want to do to
simplify this guy here
is I want to do the following.
I'm going to use the fact--
I'm going to write it in
terms of the field strength
by using the fact that
the commutator of two Ds
gives me a G. And the commutator
of two sigmas, I'll write--
sorry.
The commutator of
two gammas gives me
something I can call sigma.
So let me write this as the
symmetric piece and then
the anti-symmetric piece.
And I do a symmetrization
in both the fields
and the Dirac structures.
Doing DT slash DT
slash anti-commutator.
So then since it's
anti-symmetric,
it automatically forces
that anti-symmetric.
This guy is a GB nu, so for this
piece, we just get DT squared.
And this piece, once
we track all the 2s,
the i's give sigma dot G.
And so the usual way of
writing L1 is as follows.
You say L1, using this formula,
plugging it in, has two terms.
And you'll see why
when I write them down
that we wanted to do this.
OK, so that's L1 is
after plugging that in.
Now the reason to do this is
that if we ask about symmetry
breaking, that's
something that can
happen from sub-leading terms.
Lowest order, we had a
symmetry, heavy quark symmetry,
and that is broken by
these interactions.
But it's actually
broken in different ways
by these two terms.
This term here doesn't
have any spin structure,
so it doesn't break
the spin symmetry.
It does have flavor
structure because of the MQ,
so it breaks the
flavor symmetry.
So this is a kinetic
energy type correction,
and it breaks flavor symmetry
because of the dependence on Q
in the MQ.
And this guy breaks
both, because it
has a spin structure now, and
it's a magnetic moment type
term.
So it's got the sigma dot
B field type interaction.
This is what I mean by the
magnetic moment type term.
OK?
So that's what the sub-leading
power corrections look like,
and if we wanted to use the
effective theory to talk
about power corrections,
we could do that.
We're constructing them here
by knowing the full theory,
just integrating out
explicitly the fields, OK,
which is a very nice
thing if you can do it.
Now you could do
it the other way,
which would be to think
about just writing them
from the bottom up.
And there is one
way in which that's
more general than what
we've talked about,
and that's because what we
talked about was tree level.
And if you wanted to
include loop corrections,
how do we know that there's
not some other operator here
that we missed because it
just vanished at tree level,
for example?
We've seen examples
where that happens.
There's an operator that
only shows up at loop level.
So we could think about
it from the bottom up,
even though this is a top-down
effective theory, in order
to make sure we're
not missing anything.
And if we wanted to
do that, we should
enumerate all the possible
things, the symmetries and all
that we can use to constrain
the form of the operators.
So let's enumerate.
So there's the power
counting, of course.
That's pretty simple.
Here all the powers of 1 over
MQ are being made explicit,
and they just tell us
what dimension of operator
to look for, just as
in our integrating
out heavy particles.
So we just know the
dimension of the fields
that we have to put
in the numerator
from how many MQs
we're talking about.
There's gait
symmetry, of course.
So use covariant derivatives.
Very easy to take into account.
There's discreet symmetries,
charge conjugation,
parity at time reversal,
which are symmetries of QCD
if we drop the theta term.
And we can impose them as
well, and again, that's easy.
I wouldn't be making a list if
there wasn't at least one thing
that was hard and non-trivial.
But discreet
symmetries are easy.
The thing that actually is the
hardest is Lorentz symmetry.
Oh, you say, just dot Lorentz
indices into Lorentz indices.
But you have to ask the question
whether we even have Lorentzian
variance in this theory.
And it turns out that
part of the Lorentz group
was actually broken by
having this heavy quark
and doing this type of expansion
that we've been talking about.
So if you think about the
six generators of the Lorentz
group, the boosts
and the rotations,
there's a part that I could
call the transverse part, which
is transverse to the velocity.
So in the rest frame, that
would be M12, M23, and M13.
And those are the rotations.
So this i-- v is like this.
So no matter what
v you pick, there's
always three generators
that are rotations.
And then there's the boosts.
And you should
think of the boosts
as taking v mu and
then M dotted into v
and then making the
other guy transverse,
so when we denote it like that.
So the new index is transverse,
and in the rest from,
that's M01, M02, and M03.
And so introducing v mu actually
breaks the boosts' symmetry.
And if you like, you
could think the reason
it breaks the symmetry
is because it gives
a preferred frame, which is the
rest frame of the heavy quark.
If you have a preferred
frame, then you've
broken Lorentzian frames.
So that's bad.
And it turns out
there's actually
a hidden symmetry of this
effective theory that partially
restores this breaking.
And it restores it
in exactly the amount
that it needs to restore it.
That is, it restores
it at low energies.
And that's called
reparameterization invariance,
which I will write once,
and then forever more,
we talk about it as RPI,
Reparameterization Invariance.
And it's an additional symmetry
that we have on v mu itself.
So let's go back and think
about how we introduced
v mu in the first place.
So we're saying that v mu
breaks part of the cemetery,
but how did we decide
on what v mu was?
How much freedom
was there when we
defined v mu at the beginning?
If we're saying that
it breaks, then we
should know how
much freedom there
was, because a freedom
to define different vs
could restore symmetry, just
realized in a different way.
And that's what happens.
So where did it come from?
We had P, have a heavy
quark, and we split that
into two pieces, MQv plus k.
But this split into two pieces
is arbitrary by some amount.
We could move pieces back and
forth between here and here,
and we would still
have the same theory.
We have to be careful that we're
moving back pieces that don't
violate the power counting.
And that's what I mean by
somewhat arbitrary here,
not completely arbitrary.
There was a point to
doing this, because we
wanted to separate out the
big piece and the small piece.
But we could always move a
small piece back over here,
and that wouldn't change
this decomposition.
So the invariance that
you have is the following.
You can take v mu
and send it to v mu
plus some epsilon mu over MQ.
And k mu comes to k
mu minus epsilon mu.
That moves the piece back
and forth between them,
and as long as I think that
epsilon mu is some parameter
that doesn't have a power
counting in it, i.e.
it's order doesn't
have any MQs in it--
it's just something of
order lambda QCD, say--
then that makes the power
counting still true.
That was the point of
this decomposition.
And it allows us to move a
small piece back and forth.
The small piece is this epsilon.
So that's a symmetry.
That's called
reparameterization invariance.
So we have to make
sure that when
we construct our
effective theory that it
satisfies the
symmetry if we want
it to be a boost invariant--
if we want to restore boost
invariance to the theory.
So this parameter epsilon
you can think of as--
you could consider it to be
a finite reparameterization
symmetry, but you
don't really have
to worry about finite
transformations.
You can just do
the infinitesimal.
So we'll think about epsilon
mu as an infinitesimal.
And it has that counting
that I put over there.
Now v squared was equal to
1, and that's also something
we don't want to spoil.
But that's easy.
We just say that epsilon
dot v is equal to 0.
That maintains this condition.
So that means that there's
three different components
of epsilon, non-trivial
components to epsilon.
And those three
components of epsilon
are exactly related to
the three boosts here.
OK, we have a three family--
three-parameter family
of transformations,
which are the three components
of the epsilon, which,
in the rest frame, would just
be the one, the two, and three.
What did we do-- what
about the fields?
How does the field, the
Qv change under this type
of transformation?
Let me take the field
that x equals 0 for now.
So v slash on Qv,
it was equal to 0.
And if I do the transformation,
then this v slash changes.
It becomes v slash plus
epsilon slash over MQ.
Let me imagine Qv changes.
It goes to Qv plus
delta Qv, and I
have to do that on both sides.
Then I can take this--
so this thing here
is some order epsilon change.
Then I can take this equation,
and I can just solve.
So the piece that's
order epsilon
to the 0, just satisfied.
Solve for the piece
that's order epsilon,
and that gives me an
equation for delta Qv.
So rearranging this
equation, I find
that 1 minus v slash delta Qv is
epsilon slash over MQ times Qv.
And this equation
has the solution,
but delta QV is
epsilon slash over 2MQ.
Remember that epsilon
is transverse to v,
so if I push the v slash-- so
if I plug that solution in here
and I push a v slash
through the epsilon,
well, then I can push the v
slash through the epsilon,
let it hit the QV.
That's giving a factor of 2,
because it's anti-commutes.
That's this 2 here.
And then I would get what I
wrote on the right hand side.
So if it's not obvious,
check for yourself
that that's a solution.
So that's how you derive
the change to the field
under this reparameterization.
And so when we talk
about operators
and the effective
theory, we have
to worry, how does the
symmetry act on them?
And it's a kind of a
non-trivial symmetry.
Was not apparent to us
when we started, right.
[CHUCKLES]
OK.
So the full
reparameterization is v mu
goes to v plus epsilon over MQ.
And then if I take Qv of x,
then that is what I said.
There's this epsilon
slash over 2MQ piece.
This is the
transformation, so it
goes to itself plus
this extra piece.
And the fact that I take it at x
adds one little slight wrinkle,
and it just gives this
extra phase factor.
And that extra phase
factor is exactly what
encodes the change of k.
So this, if you like,
encodes that derivatives.
Should go to derivatives minus
epsilon or in momentum space,
that k should go
to k minus epsilon.
OK, so previously
we had a rule for k,
but now I've encoded
that in this phase.
OK?
So that's the symmetry
that we should look into.
So what does it do?
So what this does is it restores
invariance under boosts,
but only small boosts.
The reason that I call
them a small boost
is because epsilon here had
to be of order lambda QCD.
It couldn't have been order MQ.
That's what I mean by small.
And from the point of
view of this theory,
this is all we care about.
Because we want to
remain within the region
where the effective
theory was valid,
the whole setup of
the effective theory
involved dividing out a large
piece and a small piece.
If we allow back large
pieces, then the game is over,
and you wouldn't be
formulating correctly
the effective theory, because
you'd spoil the power counting.
OK, so this is this
hidden symmetry
we're calling
reparameterization variance.
And it's not special to HQET.
Any time you have fields that
are labeled by something,
you should think about whether
there's a symmetry like this.
OK, so that's the entire
list of the symmetries
that you should
consider in order
to think about doing a
bottom-up approach to HQET.
Simple ones, and then
there's this one that's
a little more complicated.
So let's go back and
now consider the 1
over MQ operators in general.
And it turns out that there's
not any missing operators,
that the two operators
we have are actually
the complete set that
you can write down
at this dimension using all
the properties of the field.
So we didn't miss anything
from that point of view.
So let me write them down
again, and let me write them
down in a way where I imagine
that radiative corrections have
come in as well.
And I'll give them some
Wilson coefficients,
which are generically
called Ck and Cf.
That's the standard notation.
So this is a Wilson coefficient.
That's a Wilson coefficient.
This is not 4/3.
it's Wilson coefficient.
The name is the same
as the Cf that is 4/3,
but this is a little
cf, not a big CF.
So if we want to--
so it's gauge invariant.
It has the right parity,
et cetera, et cetera.
We should worry about the
reparameterization invariance.
So let's do that.
So at lowest order, the
phase is what changes.
And the leading order
Lagrangian is invariant,
because v dot epsilon is 0.
So at order MQ to the 0,
since v dot epsilon is 0,
you don't get a
leading order change.
So our Lagrangian was variant.
This invariance, this
reparameterization invariance
mixes orders.
It connects orders
in the expansion.
There was a term that was
order 1, which is this piece,
and there's a term
that's order 1 over MQ.
So the symmetry
is actually making
a connection between leading
order and sub-leading order
operators.
So we could ask
about this delta L 0,
and there will be a
piece at order 1 over MQ.
So let's just write
out all these things.
Transforming everything.
This is our leading
order Lagrangian.
After imposing the field
change as well as v change,
the v dot D becomes this,
and the field becomes that.
So there's three things
here that are being changed.
Expand this out.
Use things like 1
plus v slash over 2,
epsilon slash 1
plus v slash over 2.
C equal to epsilon
dot v is equal to 0.
Simplify, do some Dirac
algebra, and you can boil this
down to something
simple, which is
that the entire change
is just an epsilon dot
D over MQ times QV.
And if you look at this, it
has to cancel against something
that's order 1 over MQ.
And if you look at the terms
that we had at order 1,
which are 1 over MQ,
there was a kinetic piece.
We called it kinetic
energy piece.
And if we do the
change there, there
is a contribution from
the phase in this case,
because we had
transverse derivatives.
So we can add epsilon
dot D transverse.
That's non-zero.
And if you go through
the leading order
change to this guy, as
well as the guy that's
the magnetic guy, you
find that the magnetic guy
is 0 at this order.
It's non-zero at higher orders,
but at this order, it's zero.
And the kinetic guy does
have a transformation.
It has exactly the same
form as this guy here.
And if epsilon's dotted into
the D, then it's a D transverse.
But this guy has a
Wilson coefficient.
This guy doesn't.
So in order for these
to cancel, you actually
learn something non-trivial.
The symmetry teaches you
something non-trivial
about the sub-leading
Lagrangian.
That Wilson
coefficient has to be
1 to [INAUDIBLE]
perturbation theory in order
for the symmetry
not to be violated.
AUDIENCE: But you are
enforcing the symmetry?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So the symmetry is
boost invariance,
and it seems like a
reasonable symmetry to impose.
Yeah.
It'd be small boosts.
So as long as your
scheme and your regulator
don't break the symmetry,
which is always something
that you have to worry
about in general,
then this guy is
1 to all orders.
OK?
So if you did something like
dimensional regularization
and you thought you
should calculate this guy,
you'd just find
that it would be 1.
And you'd wonder,
well, why is that?
It's the symmetry
that tells you it's 1.
OK, so you don't have
to figure out that guy.
The other guy, which
we've called Cf,
you do have to figure out,
because it wasn't constrained.
And at lowest order,
the other coefficient
is not constrained in this way.
And so it does get an
anomalous dimension.
And so we could calculate it.
It's a good homework problem.
You may see it on a
future homework set.
And there is an
anomalous dimension,
and when you solve that
you're again getting
something that's
the ratio of alphas
to some power.
In this case, it's a non Abelian
power, so the adjoint Casimir.
OK, so that guy does have
an anomalous dimension.
I think we'll stop there today.
And we'll talk more
about power corrections
and the phenomenology
of them, how
we can make non-trivial
predictions of from them
next time.